As descendants of apes, there remains a lingering
ape in all of us that continues to provoke
many of our behavioral and social traits.
In particular, one of the most apparent characteristics
that we continue to share with our ape relatives
is the desire for the social position of alpha
male.
In the ape world, the alpha male is everything.
He gets his pick of mates, ownership of territory,
and control over his group.
All of which are not far from the same desired
interests of most men, and often women, in
the modern human world.
So what does it take to become an alpha?
In the ape world, there are several factors
at play that determine who becomes the alpha.
They include things like size, loudness, and
the ability to dominate others as unequals.
In the human world, becoming this sort of
domineering alpha involves most of the same
factors.
We can intimidate other humans into submission
through size, intensity, and force.
And if we live with these behaviors, we can
become this same sort of alpha.
But how does the function of this position
compare in human world?
How do the differences between humans and
apes weigh in on the value of such a domineering
behavioral archetype?
The principal difference between human and
ape is the depth of our consciousness.
It is still unclear as to what degree our
consciousness extends beyond our ape relatives,
but the majority of researchers and philosophers
can agree that we have a largely superior
ability to exhibit a consciousness that allows
for self-awareness and critical reflection.
We have passed a threshold of mental complexity
where we can now think about thinking.
We can consider our intentions and how our
actions may affect others.
We can take it one step further and consider
how others’ reactions to our actions will
make us feel and think about ourselves.
And we can employ reason, empathy, and morality
to act accordingly.
As a result, even though we may still have
an ape in us who hungers to be that of a domineering
alpha, our higher human consciousness caters
to a different type of alpha.
For example, being an ape-like alpha and getting
the pick of any woman may sound appealing,
but it does not really help with the pairing
of the right man with the right woman.
In the ape world, the goal of the alpha is
to have sex and reproduce with as many mates
as possible, not to form intimate relationships.
But in the human world, we want relationships.
We want to find partners who we can exchange
love with and help balance out each other’s
lives.
And in the context of friendships, behaving
as a dominating and forceful individual may
acquire you yes-men and followers but not
necessarily any true friends, because rarely
does anyone want to continue in a long-term
friendship comprised of dominance, fear, and
hierarchy.
In a true friendship, we want mutual trust,
respect, and affinity.
Therefore, we must consider how our primal
desire to be a domineering alpha affects our
life and appropriately regulate it.
Our ape self is constantly lingering within
us and it is not simple or easy to overcome.
But by using our faculty for higher consciousness
to understand our behaviors and their affects,
we can construct and execute a new refined
concept of alpha.
A conscious alpha.
We did not evolve over millions of years to
merely continue to perpetuate the behaviors
of our lesser ancestors.
Becoming a true human alpha involves being
able to adapt to the terms of the current
human condition.
To infuse rationality, self-awareness, and
empathy into our behavior.
More important than being big and loud and
forceful, is being someone who can exhibit
compassion and reason.
Someone who is comfortable enough with themselves
to not feel a need to always compete for a
sense of self worth.
Someone who is conscious enough to practice
control over their mind and body.
We humans function better off of solidarity,
compassion, and intellect, and so it is these
qualities that we must attend to if we wish
to truly be a prevailing human.